les flics hors de nos quartiers
c'est ce qu'on pouvait lire sur les
banderoles des manifestants à athènes ce
mardi environ 5000 personnes ont défilé
dans la capitale grecque contre les
violences policières
des échauffourées ont éclaté dans la
soirée les forces de l'ordre ont fait
usage de gaz lacrymogènes comme on peut
le voir sur ces images aériennes publiée
par la police grecque
des cocktails molotov ont été lancés sur
le commissariat de nea smyrni c'est dans
cette banlieue pourtant réputé calme
qu'un jeune homme a été frappé dimanche
à coups de matraques par un policier
lors d'un contrôle des mesures de
confinement
face à cette escalade de violence le
premier ministre grec appel au calme
il est vrai sequana jouer h les tristes
images de violence que nous avons tous
vu ce soir à athènes doivent être les
dernières la vie d'un concitoyen
le jeune policier qui était en danger
doit être un signal d'alarmé dans ces
moments là maîtrise de soi et le calme
doit prévaloir
je ne permettrai à personne de nous
diviser les forces de l'ordre et les
habitants de nea smyrni ont deux
versions différentes des faits qui se
sont déroulés dimanche les policiers
affirmant avoir été pris à partie par
une trentaine de personnes lors de
contrôles du respect du couvre-feu
onze personnes ont été interpellées du
côté des habitants on assure que l'homme
frappé par le policier voulait
simplement discuter avec les agents
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
et par la police en interne